ja ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich zu
dieser ersten sitzung zum seminare cantz
freiheitsbegriff 1786 bis 1800
rekonstruktion einer debatte aber es
geht in diesem seminar um was ganz
spannendes nämlich um eine sehr
unbekannt debatte die jetzt in der
jüngsten zeit immer mehr ins interesse
der forschung geraten ist und die jetzt
immer mehr erforscht wird und dieses
seminar hat deswegen auch so ein
bisschen forschungs charakter wir werden
uns mit texten befassen die bislang noch
fast unbekannt sind und die werden wir
hier fast erstmalig diskutieren also was
sie jetzt hier im seminar machen ist
wirklich neuland das kennt noch niemand
und sie könnte also ganz vorne mit dabei
sein und jetzt sage ich ganz kurz was
zur sitzung ist was zum formalen das
ablauf des seminars dann informationen
zu prüfungsleistungen inhaltlich ist das
seminar ich die kurz auf dem seminarplan
ein den ich ihnen auch schon herum
geschickt habt ihr auch dann unten in
der beschreibung des videos im anschluss
zu sehen sein wird und ich werde am ende
ist ein paar zitate von immanuel kant
präsentieren über die wieder noch kurz
diskutieren können natürlich deine
privaten und nicht öffentlichen rahmen
zuerst mal was vom alles zum ablauf des
seminars sie haben wie sie mitbekommen
haben ist dieses semester jetzt wieder
virtuell wie schon das letzte semester
viele dachten oh hoffentlich kann es
doch wieder ganz normal fühlte
stattfinden aber so war es eben nicht
wir müssen weiterhin virtual
unterrichten
ich bin deswegen gar nicht so traurig
weil ich der meinung bin dass virtuelle
lehre sehr viele vorzüge hat und die
können wir hier über suchen recht gut
nutzen es gibt immer neuere methoden
eure wege die wir noch bescheiden können
aber ich finde das ist ein sehr gutes
mittel um virtuellen
zu betreiben wir können unterscheiden
zwischen synchrone und asynchrone lehre
synchrone lehre ist das was wir jetzt
gerade machen also echtzeit wir
diskutieren im virtuellen raum
hast du im grunde lehre ist sowas zum
beispiel wenn ich jetzt auf moodle ein
paar dateien stelle und sieht es dann
danach bearbeiten und wir danach wieder
darüber diskutieren ich finde synchrone
lehre virtuelle im westen
es gibt ein digitales begleit angebot
sie bekommt die ganzen texte die wir
hier behandeln digital zugänglich und
auch die prüfungsleistungen die werden
digital ablaufen
indem sie mir nehme ich dann einfach
ihre hausarbeit per pdf schicken
das gar kein problem also virtuelle
lehre ist meiner überzeugung nach nicht
bloße simulation oder mir spielerei es
ist was was man ernst nehmen muss und
was neue räume und möglichkeiten
eröffnet
oben rechts im video nachher auf youtube
mache ich auch ein link zu einem anderen
video von mir rein wo ich ein bisschen
genauer auf die chancen und
möglichkeiten virtueller lehre eingehen
virtuelle und analoge lehrern ergänzen
sich hier sollten die nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen und synchrone
live lehrern und asynchronen
nachbereitung zum beispiel
zusammenfassung gewisse arbeitsaufträge
können sich sehr sehr gut bewerten und
das wollen wir auch in diesem seminar in
diesem semester ton
jetzt hatte ich schon erzählt was vom
youtube kanal auf dem ich dann diese
einleitenden worte jetzt stellen werden
gleich danach dass der kanal viel
lokaler ist viele kennen sicherlich
schon von ihnen die in meinem vorherigen
semestern waren sind im land waren die
hat mittlerweile schon fast 3000
abonnenten und auf diesem kanal stelle
ich und andere doziert der lmu
regelmäßig aufzeichnung ihrer
veranstaltung aber auch sonstige
interessante videos die philosophisch
von
das ist schauen sie mal vorbei flog
lassen sie im abonnement oder wenn sie
wollen
sie bekomme immer die neuesten infos
dann habe ich noch eines seminars
erstellt für lukas app gibt es kostenlos
für android und apple
so sieht die außen und in diesem menü
können sie auch dann immer meine seminar
zusammenfassung oder auch die
aufzeichnung des jeweiligen seminares
direkt zu sagen über die app starten und
haben damit dann ein seminar für die
hosentasche kann ich sie empfehlen ist
kostenlos und habe ich extra für diesen
anlass auch erstellt und hier in diesem
seminar ordner finden sie alle
vergangenen veranstaltungen sie könnte
gut über hin und her klicken und sie
sehen dann auch dass die jeweiligen
zusammenfassung vernetzt sind die
kleinen hypertext wieso kleines wiki
also ich denke das lohnt sich sehr für
sie auch das ist das digitale begleiter
angebot jetzt zeige ich noch kurz was zu
den prüfungsleistungen also wenn sie
sich hier mit einer prüfung der am ente
betätigen wollen können sie eine
hausarbeit schreiben circa 40.000
zeichen der abgabetermin ist nach
jetzigem stand der 31 märz 2021 falls
sich keine änderung ergeben sollten kann
immer noch was anderes passieren senden
sie dann einfach alle hausarbeiten und
essays per e-mail einfach an mich
pünktlich bis mitternacht an diese e
mail adresse und ich bestätige ihnen
den erhalt nehmen sie bitte rechtzeitig
kontakt mit mir auf wegen des themas
dass wir das absprechen können gibt
viele spannende themen ich werde auch
möglich aus arbeitsthemen bekanntgeben
und sie können wir dann jederzeit ein
kurzes exposé per e mail schicken indem
sie auf ihr mögliches hansaplatz thema
eingehen
literatur also sowohl primär literatur
die quellen als auch die
sekundärliteratur mache ich ihnen gerne
online individuell zugänglich
ja jetzt noch was zum ablauf des
seminars also diese virtuelle sitzung
dauert zirka eine stunde in der
vergangenheit im letzten semester hatte
die immer so eineinhalb stunden gedauert
halte ich ein bisschen für zu lang
so lange kann man sich nicht so gut
konzentrieren virtuellen in den ersten
30 minuten gebe ich eine art
zusammenfassung und eine einführung in
die jeweilige thematik dieser teil wird
jetzt wie auch der gerade aufgezeichnet
und im anschluss auffüllung festgestellt
dann findet im privaten raum der nicht
aufgezeichnet wird eine diskussion statt
auch circa 30 minuten mal mehr mal
weniger
im anschluss verschicke ich dann die
texte und die leitfragen für die
folgende sitzung
anziehen und ich stelle die aufzeichnung
der einführung auf philo cast und
schreibe auch noch eine kleine
zusammenfassung die sie dann auch per e
mail bekommen und die sie aber auch über
die film cast capt dann vor sich haben
können ja jetzt haben wir dann
interessantes thema ganz
freiheitsbegriff von 1786 bis 1800 dazu
haben wir ein paar leitfragen spannende
frage ist die wii lässt sich menschliche
willensfreiheit angesichts der kausalen
determination der welt denken immer
anerkannt ist so der ausgangspunkt
dieser debatte und der behauptet eben
dass die welt und auch wir völlig causa
alte terminiert sind durch das
naturgesetz dass wir aber der noch frei
sind so eine art kompatibel ist muss von
natur determination und freiheit und wir
müssen uns jetzt überlegen wie man sich
sowas denken kann
eine weitere frage in diesem seminar ist
wie können wir einem skeptizismus
bezüglich menschlicher freiheit begegnen
mit welchen argumenten einige denker
dieser debatte die waren ganz schön
modernen und die hatten wie auch viele
heutige denkerin und denker die freiheit
bestritten und zwar mit guten argumenten
haben wenn alles determiniert ist wie
können wir dann überhaupt noch frei sein
und das sind also dann auch
freiheitskämpfer die dieser debatte wort
ergreifen und die dann aber auch
widerlegt werden von verschiedenen
denkern
worin besteht das charakteristikum
moralischer freiheit ist eine freiheit
zum bösen denkbar und wenn ja wie genau
das war auch eine große debatte um
dieses thema und dann nicht zuletzt wie
ist das subjekt der freiheit denken also
wer ist da eigentlich frei der mensch
ein intelligentes wesen ein empirisches
wesen oder eine einheit von
intelligenten und sensiblen wesen wie
verhalten sich zueinander
das ist auch eine ganz
andere frage jetzt zum seminar plan
wir werden erst uns befassen mit
immanuel kants philosophie und seiner
tanz zentralen und praktischen freiheit
ich sagte ja später noch ein bisschen
was genau dazu und der freiheit der
willkür
das ist auch eine konzeption von
freiheit als wahl und die war in dieser
debatte ziemlich umstritten
dann lesen wir von johann heinrich
ulrich eine schrift über determinismus
und in dpa - die er erneut technologie
also freiheits lehre genannt hat das war
eine form von interpretation der
kantischen theorie die aber eigene wege
beschritten hatte und kann auf eine ganz
eigene weise ausgelegt hat und die dann
aber auch zu diskussionen gesorgt haben
dann karl christian schmid der hat die
position eines intelligent fatalismus
vertreten nach diesen internet
fatalismus sind wir nur frei moralisch
guten handlungen und bei moralisch bösen
handlungen sind werden nicht frei
also wir sind so ein fatalistisch nur
frei im guten und das ist natürlich auch
eine problematische auffassung leonhard
kreuzer ist einer dieser skeptiker von
denen ich sprach die also die
möglichkeit von freiheit in der
damaligen debatte in frage gestellt habe
johann gottlieb fichte dem kennen sie
wahrscheinlich eher der hatte sich dann
sehr intensiv mit kreuzer mit diesem
skeptiker befasst und sucht die freiheit
zu verteidigen ein großer anhänger
calyon hat rein heute ist auch ein
bisschen bekannter der hat ebenso wie
fichte versucht für die freiheit zu
reden oder zu sprechen und er hat sich
vor allem gegen diesen carl-christian er
hat schmid und sein in die regionen
fatalismus gewinnen friedrich schiller
den kennen sie auch vielleicht eher aus
anderen kontexten ihr als ein dichter
auch der hat ihm diese freiheits debatte
eingegriffen und er hat sich vor allem
mit der frage befasst wie wir den
menschen denken müssen wenn er freies
wesens sein soll
und wenn er nicht nur als ein intensives
und nicht nur als naturwesen betrachtet
werden soll sondern als eine einheit von
natur und vernunft dass es diese frage
nach dem subjekte freiheit zu der
schüler sehr interessante dinge
beigesteuert hat dann eine ein serum
bekannte denker johann heinrich absicht
der hat versucht willensfreiheit zu
reduzieren also abzuleiten und auf dass
ich das trans zentrale ich das auch im
handel kant herausgestellt hatte zu
beziehen
wer sich jetzt schon dafür interessiert
für den machen oben rechts dann im video
einen link zu einem vortrag von mir
hinein indem ich diese frage nach
arbeitsbegriff nachgekommen bin dann
friedrich wilhelm joseph schelling der
ist auch bekannter wir haben in münchen
eine schellingstraße gleich neben der
universität der hat versucht zwischen
kant und reinhold zu vermitteln in der
frage nach der individuellen freiheit
der freiheit der willkür und zum schluss
werden wir uns fassen mit die aktualität
dieser nach kantischen debatte ich
glaube nämlich dass die gegenwärtige
freiheits debatte sehr viele
ähnlichkeiten aufweist zu der
historischen debatte und dass die
aktuelle debatte durchaus profitieren
kann wenn sie auf die historische
debatte rücksicht nimmt und auf der
anderen seite können wir auch die
historische debatte besser verstehen
wenn wir begriffe der gegenwärtigen
debatte wie kompatibel ist muss
inkompatibel ist muss und so weiter und
sofort auf sie anwenden also ich glaube
dass die sich gegenseitig befruchten
können
als ausblick werden wir haben uns mit
der gegenwärtigen debatte bisschen
befassen und vor allem texte von harel
frankfurt ließen ich bin aber ganz offen
von für ihre vorschläge sie können mir
gerne auch unter diesem video dann
vorschläge machen wie ich aktuelle
debatte viren handelt und auf die
historische beziehen soll
soviel zum seminar plan jetzt haben wir
leitfragen der heutigen sitzung was ist
der unterschied zwischen willensfreiheit
und handlungsfreiheit da sind jetzt ein
paar grundlegende dinge die wir vorher
klären sollten bevor wir auf die debatte
näher eingehen wie bestimmt immanuel
kant die willensfreiheit und welche
probleme enthält ganz freiheitsbegriff
werden den nächsten sitzungen und
ausführlicher auf ganz freiheitsbegriff
eingehen
ich möchte jetzt ein leiden nur so ein
paar zitate von ihm mal präsentieren
dass wir so einen eindruck davon
gewinnen wie die debatte konturiert ist
jetzt möchte ich erst mal ein bisschen
was zum thema handlungsfreiheit sagen
handlungsfreiheit ist eine auffassung
von freiheit die ganz alltäglich ist das
ist zum beispiel wenn sie sagen ich bin
doch frei ich kann doch meine hand heben
das zeigt doch dass ich frei bin dann
sagen sie damit ich kann tun was ich
will
als handlungsfreiheit bedeute tun können
was man will
ich kann doch die hand heben kann doch
diese schöne tasse mit diesen noten
nehmen und daraus was trinken kann ich
doch
also bin ich doch frei jetzt kann man
sich aber überlegen genügt dass freiheit
mit tun können was man will zu
identifizieren es gibt noch eine andere
position
die nennt sich willensfreiheit und die
besagt nicht tun kann was man will sein
wollen können was man will ja was ist
jetzt da der unterschied also
handlungsfreiheit hat eben dieses
problem dass der wille schon gesetzt ist
wenn man etwas will wenn da ein wille in
uns da ist und wir diesen willen
nachkommen
dann sind wir frei aber
handlungsfreiheit fragt nicht danach ist
das wirklich unser viele wollen wir das
wirklich so der wille wird gesetzt jetzt
kann man sich natürlich vorstellen dass
uns von außen ein wille eingepflanzt
wird dass wir manipuliert werden
hypnotisiert werden und danach hin uns
ein wille verspüren
und wenn wir dem nachkommen können dann
wären wir frei aber nur
handlungsfreiheit winfrey
willensfreiheit bedeutet also dass man
den eigenen willen kontrolliert und
selbst hervorgebracht hat dass man also
auch autor des willens ist und nicht nur
auto der handlung also willensfreiheit
ist noch viel grundsätzlicher radikalere
begriff als handlungsfreiheit und
deswegen dreht sich die ganze debatte
die wir jetzt behandelt vor allem um den
begriff der willensfreiheit und nicht so
sehr im begriff der handlungsfreiheit
das ist jetzt eine unterscheidung die
recht modern ist die damals auch schon
ungefähr zu existierte aber das ist
jetzt eine unterscheidung der
gegenwärtigen debatte die wir jetzt
schon auf die historische debatte
angewendet haben also es geht in dieser
debatte wesentlich um willensfreiheit
wie müssen wir unseren will und
bestimmen kontrollieren dass er frei
genannt werden kann
und jetzt möchte ich noch ein paar
zitate von dem anerkannt zur einleitung
gehen mal präsentieren also im anerkannt
geboren 1724 und gestorben 1804 dazu
muss sie noch vorab ein paar abkürzungen
ihnen erklären da müssen sie jetzt mal
gut aufpassen
also a ha ist die akademie ausgabe das
ist immer der band der akademie
jahresgabe nachdem kanzlerin zitiert
werden krv ist die kritik der reinen
vernunft von 1781 gms die grundlegung
zur metaphysik der sitten das sind diese
werke von 17 85 die die wichtigsten
stellen zu kants freiheitsbegriff
enthalten kpv ist die kritik der park
schon fünf von 1788 ist die religion
schrift oder die religion innerhalb der
grenzen der bloßen vernunft von 17 93
und zuletzt die metaphysik der sitten
von 1797 in der kant abschließend etwas
zum thema bildungsfreiheit gesagt hat
also diese sechs schriften oder fünf
schriften genauer von der kritik der
reinen vernunft bis zum mittag für sie
kassierten die stehen jetzt in den
ersten sitzungen unseres seminars im
zentrum und wir werden dann genauer
schauen wie diese historischen dekker
auf diese schriften reagiert haben
ich kann schon so viel sagen in der
kritik der reinen vernunft da entwickelt
die ganz abstrakten grundlagen seines
freiheitsbegriff da geht es um die frage
wie freiheit als idee als fähigkeit eine
kausalität spontan in die welt zu setzen
also so was wie eine absolute ursache zu
sein die nicht wiederum weitere ursachen
hat in der vergangenheit zurückgreifen
so eine absolute ursache zu setzen oder
ihnen das auch eine freiheits kausalität
in gang zu setzen
und wie diese freiheits qualität mit der
natur kausalität eben nicht absolut ist
dann von der es immer wieder weitere
vorläufer gibt es unendliche zurück wie
diese zwei formen von kausalität
miteinander vereinbar sind
diese frage behandelt kann in der kritik
der einfall der grundlegung zur
metaphysik der sitten geht es dann darum
diese freiheit die er in der kritik
bestimmt hat weiter aus zu
differenzieren und zwar vor allem in
moralischer hinsicht verkannt ist
freiheit oder falls kausalität
moralische freiheit also freiheit die
dem sittengesetz dem kategorischen
imperativ gehorcht so begründet kann
held des willens der kritik der
praktischen vernunft analysiert er denn
diese moralischen freiheitsbegriff noch
genauer in der religionsstifter
interessiert sich kann vor allem für die
individuelle freiheit die freiheit der
willkür und auch in der regel in der
mensa sitten steht der begriff der weg
führen also das vermögen zu wählen oder
auch speziell gegenüber dem guten und
dem bösen sich zu entscheiden im zentrum
kant hat vor allem in diesen letzten
schriften ganz vor allem der mitte sich
der sitten auch selbst stellung genommen
zu dieser historischen debatte also wir
haben es hier mit einem sehr komplexen
diskussions zusammenhang zu tun der
chronologisch geordnet ist beginnend mit
der kritik der reinen vernunft und die
ersten kritiker oder ersten beiträge zur
ganz freiheitsbegriff die tretens
ungefähr 17 86 88 89
seit diesem umkreis dieser zwei
schriften grundlegung und kritik der
praktisch wirkt auf vor allem wenn aber
auch in der religion schrift nimmt kann
dazu damit darstellung und auch in der
metaphysik der sitten also hier hängt
alles miteinander zusammen und das macht
diese debatte ist spannend und fruchtbar
jetzt lese ich mal ihnen hier ein zitat
von ihm anerkannt sie sehen schon unten
rechts das ist aus der kritik der
praktischen vernunft in der akademie
ausgabe band 5 seite 97 bis man vorher
nicht abschrecken lassen dass es jetzt
ziemlich kompliziert eben um das wählen
kann man auch alle notwendigkeit der
begebenheiten in der zeit nach dem
naturgesetze der kausalität dem
mechanismus der natur nennen ob man
gleich darunter nicht versteht dass
dinge die im unterworfen sind wirkliche
material
immer schön sein müssten hier wird nun
nur auf die notwendigkeit der
verknüpfung der begebenheiten in einer
zeitreihe so wie sie sich nach dem
naturgesetz entwickelt gesehen nacken
das objekt welche dieser ablauf
geschieht automaten material da das
maschinenwesen durch materie oder mit
leibniz spirituelle da es durch
vorstellung betriebenen nennen und wenn
die freiheit unseres willens keine
andere als die letztere etwa die
psychologische und komparative nicht
trans en tale das ist absolut zugleich
wäre so würdest du im grunde nichts
besser als die freiheit eines beraten
wenn das sein der auch wenn wir einmal
aufgezogen worden von selbst seine
bewegung verrichtet sie sehen jetzt hier
in diesem zitat verschiedene
freiheitsbegriff die kant einführen also
mit bezug auf leibnitz und auf andere
denker vor allem natürlich auf leibnitz
spricht er von einer komparativen
freiheit von einer psychologischen
freiheit von einer freiheit des braten
wenders die er gegenüber stellt einer
anderen auffassung von freiheit die er
nennt transzendentale oder absolute
freiheit
dieser unterschied von komparative
freiheit der polemisch freiheit eines
braten wenn das nimmt also praktisch ein
braten wenn der einmal aufgezogen wird
und sich dann immer wieder dreht diesen
unterschied kann man ungefähr ganz
ungefähr nicht genau wo ungefähr analog
sehen zum verhältnis von
handlungsfreiheit und willensfreiheit
also handlungsfreiheit fragt nicht so
sehr nach derart unserem
das bestimmen und lässt deswegen zu dass
der wieder schon von jemand anderem
bestellt ist wenn zwei hingegen ist das
was kann ungefähr unter trans zentraler
absoluter freiheit versteht absolut
deswegen weil wir selbst die ursachen
unseres wollen sind und dieses wurden
selbst nicht wieder von etwas anderen
bestimmt sein kann zb durch die natur
kausalität oder die etwas anderes das
ist also jetzt hier ein sehr wichtiges
zitat wir müssen noch genau schauen was
es psychologische komparative und
freiheit aber das ist sehr prominent und
das sollten wir jetzt immer im
hinterkopf haben
hier sehen wir wie kann seine weiter
steht und wogegen er sie abgrenzen
weiteres zitat aus der religions-
schrift in der akademie als geplant
sechs seite 44 lautet was der mensch im
moralischen sinne ist oder werden zurück
oder böse dazu muss er sich selbst
machen oder gemacht haben beides muss
eine wirkung seiner freien willkür sein
denn sonst könnte es ihm nicht
zugerechnet werden folglich der wieder
moralisch gut noch böse sein
hier kommt jetzt eine andere dimension
von freiheit ins zentrum nämlich die
freiheit zu wählen zwischen gut oder
böse und diese freiheit des willens
nennt er die freiheit der willkür die
freiwillige willkür bedeutet so viel wie
die wahl des willens führen bedeutet
wählen sie kennen das bei
sportveranstaltungen eine kür ansteht
oder wenn jemand auserkoren wird
auserwählt wird das ist auch im
englischen das wort coachings dass es
miteinander verwandt also die wilke ist
das war vermögen das wählen und
ja so denkt jetzt erkannten die willkür
die wilke die freiwillig können muss die
möglichkeit haben zwischen gut und böse
gleichermaßen wählen zu können
entscheiden zu können
also wird das entscheidungs oder wahl
das individuelle jetzt habe ich noch ein
zitat und dann gehen wir die diskussion
über ein weiteres zitat aus der
grundlegung zur metaphysik der sitten
akademie aus irland 4 seite 447 lautet
also ist ein freier wille und ein willen
unterschiedlichen gesetzen einerlei was
hat es damit auf sich das sittliche
gesetz ist verkannt natürlich der
kategorische imperativ handelt es so
dass die maxime deines willens jederzeit
zugleich als prinzip einer allgemeinen
gesetzgebung gehen könne
das ist ja in aller länge und jetzt sagt
kant in diesem zitat ein freier wille
ist dann ein wille ein feuer finden wenn
diese kategorischen imperativ diesem
sittengesetz gehorcht also wenn er unter
ihm steht
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen ist
der wille wirklich frei wenn er durch
das sittengesetz bestimmt ist wenn er
dem hinterlegt oder ist er nicht
vielleicht dadurch gerade unfreie weil
er kann ja dann wenn er die im
sittengesetz unterliegt eigentlich nur
gut handeln
und nicht böse also fehlt ihm da nicht
diese willkür wenn jetzt ein freier
wille nur ein sittlicher willis oder
wille der unter dem 7 gesetz steht
das ist eine ganz ganz zentrale frage
und an dieser frage hat sich ein
großteil dieser debatte die wir in
diesem seminar gemeinsam rekonstruieren
und diskutieren wollen
aufgehängt